(techno music)
- Then I seen, like, the Virgin Mary,
but she was stripping like she was dancing
to No Quarter. (laughter)
And I woke up from that shit.
I go, I'll never do heroin again.
But I'm lying. (laughter)
I did it in New York one time
in a gay bar up on the
third floor. (laughter)
Ramrod. Fuck it. (laughter)
Gotta take a chance.
Columbus did, right?
(intense rock music)
(applause)
- Welcome to This Is
Not Happening Presents:
One Crazy Night.
So this is what we do.
A bunch of comedians
tell stories about a similar subject.
So this is just one crazy night.
Ladies and gentlemen, my friend yours,
Mr. Joey Diaz, everybody.
(applause and cheering)
- One more time for Ari
for putting this together.
(applause and cheering)
So all messed up, you know, like half of
the motherfuckers in here
been all fucked up, all right?
(laughter)
Ah, something's always fucking us up.
For me, it was 30 years of just drugs.
And no fucking JK here. We
got down, bitch. (laughter)
All right, so, when he called me up,
and he's like hey, I
want you to do the story,
I did like a, I got high,
right, I smoked a joint, right,
(laughter)
and I made like a drug
tombstone, right. (laughter)
Like acid, you know, '79 to like '85.
And then I did like Quaaludes,
you know, '80 to '87.
And, you know, THC crystal
(laughter) and I went,
and then, you know, I
did blow for a long time.
Towards the end, in 2005, I was fucked up.
I really wanted to quit. I wanted to quit
at the 25 year mark. You
follow me? (laughter)
But I just, I couldn't do it.
Like once I hit that centennial,
I had to fucking do something.
But I had too much pride to go to a rehab.
There was a rehab on Hollywood
Boulevard next to Robek.
I went down there for like
a week under an alias,
(laughter)
but then they started snooping around.
I had to get the fuck out
of there, right. (laughter)
In the old days, you could push an alias
like a motherfucker.
After 9/11, it's tough
out there for a pimp,
you follow me? (laughter)
So fuck it, they saw that, Jose what?
Fuck you, motherfucker,
none of your business.
(laughter)
It's fucking anonymous, what's with
the questions, cocksucker? (laughter)
So. (laughter)
I had done heroin before, right.
Like when I was like
17, I stole this thing
with Didi Contero, this little
fucking crazy Cuban kid.
We stole like this thing
where you put dishes in it.
It was brand new, the people left it
in front of the people's houses.
Me and Didi picked it up
and walked five blocks
to Gunther Brown's house,
if you ask me again,
I'll knock you down, right.
This fucking guy, he was like
the neighborhood loan shark.
Like if you stole something,
he'd buy it from you.
(laughter)
So I go over there,
and I'm like, you know,
I want to sell you this.
He's like, you can drop it off
and come back in two hours.
He looked like Tony
Iommi, the guitar player
from Black Sabbath. (laughter)
And he always answered
the door with a robe
and his underwear showing,
like the fucking dude
in Boogie Nights. (laughter)
He was creepy, but not really,
you know what I'm saying?
(laughter)
Like, you had to take a chance
with this motherfucker, right? (laughter)
So he goes, come back in two hours.
I go in there, we're rocking,
we're talking shit, right.
He goes, I got your $60. So
then he's like, hang out, man.
I want to do business
and hang out with you.
You seem like a cool dude.
So I'm sitting there. He's like,
you want to do some heroin?
At the time, I had done everything, right.
Like, uh, you know, coke.
I had done, like, Tuminols.
I had done like, uh, THC
crystal, aka gorilla biscuits,
aka fucking elephant
tranquilizers. (laughter)
So I'm like, fuck it, if you want.
At this time, I was a
fucked up kid, you know.
I had no direction.
I said, fuck it, I'll
do the heroin, right.
And I did this gagger of this white
Chinese fucking heroin.
I heard, like, Chinese
music in the background.
(imitates Chinese music)
(laughter)
I do this thing, all of a sudden,
it's like the fucking
room starts spinning,
and I gotta puke, and I
puked, and I pass out,
and I think I'm dead.
But I heard, like, No
Quarter, by Jimmy Page.
The live shit, live from the Garden.
And that's how I knew I was alive.
So I got up on my hands and knees,
and I sat with the puke on my face
and fucking Jimmy was blasting.
At the five minute mark, if you listen to
The Song Remains The
Same, fucking Jimmy Page
drops it like a fucking soldier.
(laughter)
Especially when you're on heroin.
You got the tingles up
and down your back, right.
And it was on. I felt that
heroin, the warmth from God.
Like, that's what it
is. Your balls are warm,
you want to come.
But it don't matter, you
know what I'm saying.
Like you want to come, but fuck it,
it wouldn't be good enough
as the warmth you're feeling
in your body, my ears.
And I could see all these, like,
I wasn't hallucinating but it was so warm,
I was feeling like, I seen every woman
that I ever seen in my
life and made contact with.
Not sex, I was too young for that.
Like I seen the lunch
lady there, Mrs. Sabatino.
(laughter)
I seen the lady who gave
me birth, you follow me,
who smacked me in the ass.
I seen the fucking nun who I
tackled in the fourth grade.
I seen all these bitches
in this fucking dream.
I seen my mother. Then I
seen, like, the Virgin Mary.
And that's when I knew I was fucked up.
And she was stripping like
she was dancing to No Quarter.
(laughter)
And that's fucked up right there, right.
And I had already made my confirmation,
I was fucked up right there, I was
fractured as a Catholic
already at that age, right.
(laughter)
So that was it. When I
woke up from that shit,
I go, I'll never do heroin again.
But I'm lying. I did it again
at the halfway house in '94,
right, then I did it in New York one time
at a gay bar up on the
third floor, Ramrod.
That's what you do when you're up there.
Fuck it. You've gotta take a chance,
Columbus did, right?
(laughter and applause)
Gotta do heroin at a gay bar, fuck it.
That's how you know and shit.
You're over there dancing,
looking at the gay dudes and shit,
(laughter)
driving them fucking
bananas and shit. Anyway.
(laughter)
So it's 2005, I'm living in Hollywood,
and I'm doing a fucking gram
of blow a night sometimes.
That was like a bad night.
By eight o'clock every night
I'd be watching TV and I'd get
this pain in my fucking soul.
And I'd get, my bones would
hurt. I couldn't hear the TV.
Like I wanted to watch
something on TV and I couldn't.
And I get in my car and I take the ATM.
I lived on Schrader. And
I go all the way to Sunset
and fucking Hollywood Ralph's.
Rock and Roll Ralph's.
There's an ATM right there.
And I sweared on my fucking mother's grave
I wouldn't stop for a red light.
I didn't give a fuck,
I didn't give a fuck.
I parked right in front of there,
put my hazard lights on,
fuck it, like a doctor.
(laughter)
Without a handicap sticker,
I don't give a fuck.
(laughter)
I take out 60 bucks and right
there I call the drug dealer.
I had a couple of them.
The Armenian only came on the weekends.
(laughter)
The black guy was there every night,
and the Mexican motherfucker was there
like four nights a week, depending
what shift he was working.
So I knew all their shifts and shit.
So I would go buy a gram, go home,
do it in the fucking garage, go upstairs,
make believe I was shitting and jerk off
in the bathroom or look
out the fucking window.
That was the extent of
my fucking addiction
at the time.
Then at two o'clock
when it would wear off,
I called another drug dealer so
they wouldn't know my addiction, right.
Now, was I going to go to
a fucking rehab? Fuck no.
So I'm talking to a buddy of mine one day.
After 9/11, he moved back to Newark.
I go, I say, you living with your mother?
He's like forty something.
I go, so do you still do heroin?
He goes like, fuck yeah, every night.
He goes, I cop down in Newark.
I cop seven dollar bags of heroin.
I go, send me a couple.
Now.
You ever have a
conversation with somebody,
and they, you just try to be cool.
You're like, yeah, count me in.
Wrong fucking dude, right. (laughter)
(laughs) About a week
later, I go to my mailbox.
And it was in like
Crayola writing, you know.
(laughter)
Like, Joey, Koko. He spelled Koko wrong.
With two K's and shit. Diaz, right.
And I'm like, what the fuck? (laughter)
No return address, right.
I take it upstairs.
I open it, and there they are.
Three little fucking bags of H.
White, that Chinese
shit that the terrorists
are bringing in like a
motherfucker. (laughter)
By the day load with a
picture of Obama on it,
balls ass naked, (laughter)
smoking a joint and
shit, with a white chick
licking his fucking nuts,
like a doctor, right.
So I'm like, fuck it. So
I'm, I'm doing the blow
every night, so there's Monday night.
I go, fuck it, tonight's
a different night.
I'm doing, like a little line of this H.
And I usually, what I would
do, I was fucking crazy.
My girlfriend's great. She don't get high.
So I would trick her. I'd go,
you gotta go to bed, dog.
You gotta get eight hours. (laughter)
You're at that age. You need
every fucking (mumbles).
Don't worry about me.
I'm a fucking comedian.
This is what I do. (laughter)
You gotta go to bed right now.
While all this is going on,
there was a cat population
growing in my backyard.
(laughter)
And I had already adopted three
of these little motherfuckers, right?
And they had, the problem
was, they had two.
They had the mama, who was a dirty whore,
and then they had two big
cats that were slinging dick
like, you know. (laughter)
They had the Siamese, the
warbler, I called him the Samurai.
He had big black balls.
(laughter) But he was Siamese.
I'm not kidding you. When he'd walk,
he'd walk all fucked up. (laughter)
Like this guy fucking meant it.
Never talked to me, nine years.
Never took a lobster, nothing.
He was a soldier. He'd just stare me down.
Fuck you, bitch. You ain't
buying my fucking love,
cocksucker, right.
(laughter)
Then there was a black and
white one who was a big cat,
and they were both fucking mama,
so she kept having kittens.
And then they would kill the kittens
so she would stop ovulating
and get back to fucking.
This is how serious these
motherfucking cats were, right.
(laughter)
Now how did I learn about this? You know,
I did some reading on the internet.
When you're doing coke,
you stay up late night.
(laughter)
And you do investigating, you follow me?
So she had the kittens,
and they were beautiful.
There were three Siamese kittens.
And this one black and white
dirty motherfucker, right.
(laughter)
But the three Siameses, there
was two girls and a boy,
DJ, DJ was the best
little cat in the world.
They lived outside, and I'd
step out in my backyard,
and I'd go, DJ.
And he'd come fucking
running like a superhero.
And the two little girls would come.
And then that Superbad,
this little black and white
would come.
And like, they would
all hang out around me.
But Superbad, the black and white one,
would take DJ and take
him up trees and shit,
and take him off the territory.
Would take him on Selma by the YMCA.
And I'd have to get Superbad,
going one of these days,
I'm going to fucking kill
you, cocksucker, right.
And I caught myself. Even
though I loved the cats,
I would never put a hit on a cat.
(laughter)
But in my mind,
I'm like I'm gonna fucking kill
this little fucking cat, seriously.
And I love cats, don't get me wrong,
but do you know those
cats that just get on
your last fucking nerve.
(laughter)
And you don't know how to do it,
but you love animals too much,
so you know you just
bullshitting yourself.
So I, I'm like one day, he's just gonna
get hit by a truck or something, fucking
that little cocksucker.
Don't hang with him no more, DJ.
(laughter)
And I was just waiting
to bring DJ upstairs,
and I had a chick that was gonna take
the two Siameses, and then fuck Superbad.
I didn't know what the hell was going
to happen to Superbad, right.
So, my addiction's
getting worse and worse.
And one night I got home
and my wife was fucking,
at the time she was my
girlfriend, she's crying.
And she said, the fucking cats outside,
they're going to die.
I go what the, what are you talking about?
So we got the two girls.
We brought them to the vet,
and she adopted them out through Petco.
And then I go, what are you
going to do with Superbad,
that fucking mutt, and DJ, my baby.
And she goes, well, I'm
gonna bring them up.
And I go, leave Superbad outside.
(laughter)
Just leave him the fuck outside.
That's how much I hated Superbad.
(laughter)
So I go out one night.
And my rule was, people,
this is how fucked up in my addicted mind,
my rule was never to do coke in the house
cause it was bad luck.
(laughter)
I would always do it in the car,
so by the time I got upstairs,
I had to shit and I'd
run into the bathroom
and hide, you follow me? (laughter)
That was the fucking plan. I had a plan.
I was an organized cocaine
type of motherfucker, right.
(laughter)
So this night, something happened,
I had to go to the bathroom.
I didn't have time, I ran upstairs,
and when I got upstairs, my
wife goes in the bathroom.
The two cats are in the bathroom.
So I go in the bathroom,
and I, I do the coke,
and I'm looking at the both of them.
I'm like, I don't even know
why she fucking brought you up here.
And I go back outside, and I do the coke,
and I probably got some oh,
I don't know fucking story,
and I went to bed.
And when I got up, my wife woke me up
in the middle of the night.
She goes hey, I just want to tell you
that fucking DJ died.
And that was the Siamese that
I was gonna adopt, right.
And, ah, when she said it, guys,
I fucking knew it was the
coke. I fucking knew it.
And I just said, do me
a favor, close the door,
and I cried a little bit,
and I put the pillow,
I put my sleep apnea mask on first,
then I went to fucking bed, right.
(laughter)
Yeah, whatever, sleep apnea,
whatever the fuck it is.
I'm a fat dude, right. (laughter).
And then,
so I'm laying there thinking
I finished my crying.
I go, you know what, that little cat died
because I brought the coke upstairs.
Even if I fucking hate Superbad,
that motherfucker's not
going to die up here,
cause that's even more bad luck.
So I went in there, I
got on my hands and knees
like a Catholic fucking soldier,
and I said, God, if you
save these fucking cat,
this Superbad who I can't
stand, I'll never do coke again.
And I like, winked at
him, like right, whatever.
(laughter)
I said, God, don't let
this motherfucker die.
And I promise you, and like the first day,
I had the jitters, you
know, but every day,
I would go in the bathroom, and he'd live.
Like, by the fourth day, I was ready
to fucking shoot myself. (laughter)
I was ready just to shoot him and end it.
I would go in there like, die.
Don't you feel like dying yet?
(laughter)
It's over. You don't want to live.
It's fucking terrible. Things
are tough out there, trust me.
(laughter)
That was seven years ago,
and I haven't done blow.
I'll tell you what, I'll
tell you how close I am
with this filthy motherfucker that I love.
Cause if you go to my house
and you look at my cats,
and you look at him, and you're like, eh.
(laughter)
He's like Marilyn on the Munsters,
you follow what I'm saying to you?
(laughter)
I got good looking Siameses and he's like
black and white, and he
got a little head and shit,
but he's fearless.
Well, I'll tell you
how much that dude knew
I'd made a promise for
him, cause at night,
my other cats are cool, but
they ain't that fucking cool.
But at night, when I go in to my bedroom,
I take my slippers off, I
put my sleep apnea mask on,
I put the fan on, and I lay
down, and I pick the blanket up,
and I go, Superbad.
And wherever the fuck
this motherfucker is,
you hear, like, boom. You
hear him hit the door.
And he jumps next to me, and
I put the blanket over him,
and that's the end of the fucking night.
He's still there, cocksuckers. Stay black.
Thank Ari Shaffir one more time
for putting this together tonight.
(applause and cheers)
(techno rock music)
- OK, great.
(whimsical music)
- [Ari] Hey, why don't you click like
so that this YouTube
clip gets better views,
and subscribe so that you
can see next week's story.
And don't forget to leave a comment.
I command you.
(synthesizer)